[Music]
do you ever feel stressed about money
unless you're a prince or a preschooler
you probably said yes for a lot of
people it always feels like there's not
quite enough to go around you're
constantly having to make tough
decisions about what you can forego and
it never feels like you're really in
control of your finances well when you
need a bit of inspiration look no
further than the front of a $1 bill I'm
talking about this guy George Washington
besides being the first President of the
United States General George Washington
was the commander of the ragtag
Continental Army during the
Revolutionary War he must have felt like
he never had enough soldiers to go
around but by making a plan he was able
to lead that army to victory over the
greatest fighting force in the world you
can take a cue from George by becoming
commander-in-chief of your finances each
one of these is a soldier in your army
and your battle plan is a budget I know
the word budget makes most people want
to go AWOL in fact according to a 2016
Gallup poll only 32 percent of couples
keep a written budget of any kind but if
you were a soldier would you want to
follow a general who was making it up as
he went along a lot of people tend to
think of budgeting this prediction
estimating what you'll make in future
months and how you'll want to spend it
but the most effective budgets work
exclusively with present dollars after
all you can't give orders to soldiers
that don't exist so the size of your
army is only how much money you
currently have in your bank accounts and
as general your role is to give every
last one of those soldiers of jobs do so
if you have a total of $10,000 across
all of your accounts you need to decide
how much of that you're going to spend
this month and how much you're going to
set aside for savings before we can
decide how much we want to spend we need
to know how much we're spending now
print out your last three months of bank
statements and put each expense into one
of five categories essentials these are
the things you can't do without rent
utilities groceries gas car payments
health insurance anything you need to
live or do your job effectively
security these are expenses that
increase your financial stability like
building emergency funds or paying off
debts don't double count credit cards in
this category though if you use a card
to buy groceries that expense should go
in essentials goals this is money you
set aside to achieve big life goals like
saving up to buy a house starting your
own business or taking a special
vacation lifestyle these are expenses
that help you navigate your social world
personal grooming and apparel gifts for
friends and family gym memberships even
pet needs can go in here discretionary
this category is all about treating
yourself going out to dinner running a
movie buying a video game or getting a
massage everyone has their own
priorities but think of this as a good
battle plan template with the most
urgent needs at the top and the more
flexible ones towards the bottom now
that you know how much you generally
spend on these categories you can start
assigning your soldiers to next month's
duties unless you're living paycheck to
paycheck you probably have some money
left over but don't let those soldiers
just sit around decide what you're
saving them for is it an emergency fund
or a Hawaiian vacation savings that have
explicit purposes are a lot harder to
steal from congratulations you've made
your first month's budget now how do you
make it stick number one write it down
you can use a spreadsheet an app or good
old pencil and paper but no general ever
won a war by keeping all their strategy
up here number 2 update it conditions on
the ground will change so Reese Trat
ajay x' at the beginning of every month
and you'll have new soldiers to deploy
in next month's battles number three use
advanced technology thanks to the dozens
of budgeting apps you can download for
your phone no one has to keep a
checkbook longhand anymore this can be
especially helpful for discretionary
spending now you can know right away
whether you can afford that weird al'
album on vinyl so how do you know your
budget incorrectly well the most obvious
answer is that your
less stress imagine enjoying and dinner
out without worrying about whether or
not you can afford it imagine not
holding your breath every time you check
your account balance you'd be amazed how
much you can improve your mood just by
introducing more clarity and control
into your finances like a lot of good
financial habits the point of budgeting
isn't to have more money it's to be
happier with the money you have and
that's our two cents we want to tell you
about the new PBS Digital Studio series
say it loud
a celebration of Black History and
culture and its impact on how we live
today hosts Evelyn from the Internet's
and AZ Dungy give you a comedic take on
identity and pop culture from black
pride movements to black Twitter
shenanigans check out say it loud in the
link in the description below
you
[Music]